nos piden organizar las siguientes
unidades de medida en dos categorías las
unidades tradicionales de eeuu que vamos
a poner en color naranja y las del
sistema métrico que vamos a poner en
color azul va y después tenemos que
indicar si la unidad mide longitud peso
masa o volumen muy bien empecemos con
litro litro es una unidad del sistema
métrico así que la vamos a pintar en
color azul en color azul luego galón
galones una unidad del sistema
tradicional de eeuu así que la ponemos
de color naranja y es una unidad de
volumen pero ahorita no nos vamos a
detener en eso solo en qué tipo de
sistema
estamos vale así si íbamos a méjico y
pedimos gasolina nos la van a vender en
litros en eeuu nos van a vender la
gasolina en galones vale bueno ahora
test y gramo decigramos es una unidad
del sistema métrico y aquí ayuda mucho
saber que existen estos precios estos
prefijos como desi mili kilo que son
propios del sistema métrico nadie habla
de kilo libras por ejemplo bueno
podríamos hablar de kilo libras pero
sería raro
entonces si tenemos estos prefijos de
los cuales después vamos a platicar son
unidades del sistema métrico vale bueno
aquí tenemos milímetro misma idea
prefijo mil y quiere decir una milésima
parte de un metro milímetro
luego pie es una unidad del sistema
tradicional de eeuu kilogramo kilogramo
otra vez tiene prefijo del sistema
métrico kilogramo va centilitros
centilitro también va en color azul
también es del sistema métrico tiene el
prefijo sentí que quiere decir una
centésima parte kilo quiere decir mil
entonces kilogramos dos mil gramos bueno
seguimos tenemos tasa tasa desde el
sistema el sistema tradicional de eeuu
metro por supuesto que es del sistema
métrico verdad metro métrico libra libra
es de el sistema tradicional de eeuu y
sirve para para medir masa pero ahorita
pasamos a eso pulgada también es del
sistema tradicional de eeuu
esto ya está un poco tedioso pero ya
casi acabamos onzas desde el sistema
tradicional de eeuu
finalmente yarda también es el sistema
tradicional de estados unidos sale bueno
entonces todas estas unidades que están
en azul se utilizan en el sistema
métrico por lo tanto en casi la mayoría
del mundo y las unidades en naranja se
utilizan pues principalmente en eeuu de
hecho todo el mundo debe estar muy
frustrado con eeuu porque no se quiere
cambiar al sistema métrico pero bueno ya
son sus unidades tradicionales que le
vamos a hacer
ok ahora vamos a ver qué miden cada una
de estas unidades vale lo voy a poner en
color amarillo nos piden ver si se miden
longitud o sea como una distancia o algo
así
peso masa que más o menos es lo mismo
bueno no realmente peso tiene que ver
como con la fuerza de atracción que
tiene la tierra sobre un objeto o un
objeto sobre otro y masa tiene que ver
con la cantidad de materia que tenemos
de ese objeto pero si estamos en la
tierra pues se usan casi sin distinción
vale entonces las vamos a pensar como la
misma cosa ahorita o volumen y volumen
es cuánto espacio ocupa entonces
longitud es distancia peso masa es
cuánto es o bien con cuánta fuerza aloja
la tierra
y finalmente volúmenes cuánto espacio
ocupa bueno vamos a cada una de estas
litro y litro mide qué tanto espacio
ocupa algo y por lo tanto es una unidad
de volumen volumen volumen galón también
es una unidad de volumen volumen volumen
sí podemos decir cuánta gasolina o guano
cuánto espacio ocupa cierta gasolina
midiendo son litros o galones ahora
tenemos decigramos decigramos el prefijo
es decir lo que nos importa es gramo
para saber qué mide y gramo es una
unidad de masa de más sale milímetro es
una unidad de longitud porque tiene el
prefijo mili pero lo que nos importa
ahorita es metro y metro es una unidad
de longitud longitud sale y también es
una unidad de longitud longitud
aquí tenemos kilogramo mil gramos y los
gramos mide en masa esta es una unidad
de masa centilitro pues ya dijimos que
el litro es de volumen entonces esto
mide volumen
volumen tasa es una unidad que mide
volumen también volumen metro metro es
una unidad de longitud de longitud
longitud
saleh libra es una unidad de peso una
libra es nos dice pues que tanto tenemos
de un objeto nos dice el peso de uno
bueno la masa con cuánto con cuánta
atracción lo jala la tierra vale pulgada
a pulgada es una unidad de longitud para
una longitud pequeña verdad longitud
unsam con 11 hay que ser cuidadosos y
simplemente dice onzas entonces esto de
aquí es una dieciseisava parte de una
libra y por lo tanto es una unidad de
masa de masa pero si dijera onza líquida
entonces sería una dieciseisava parte de
una pinta y por lo tanto me diría
volumen pero ahorita me de masa vale y
yarda
finalmente yarda es una unidad de
longitud longitud bueno con esto
terminamos el problema